[Musique]
jimmy waite direct tu peux pas de garder
tu viens de te faire virer on m'a pas
gardé pour cause de responsabilité au
niveau des assurances lui un peu de
respect la cour du charlotte motor
speedway
je sais comment circulent d'argent
le frêle qui était exactement comment
faire exploser une sombre forme de banc
des jo bang
je suis en quarts c'est triste mais on a
un plan pour faire sortir
la coca cola 600 et la plus grande
course la mise une fois un génie de
l'informatique connaître tout ce qu'il
faut connaître sur les ordinateurs
ok tout les twitter j'ai connectique par
cas ils sauront ce qu'on veut bien leur
dira pas plus
la ville criminelle pour moi infinie
allez passer facilement super 10
très près du coup je pense j'ai bien ri
ça a dû vous faire mal
[Musique]
je veux tout savoir sur 10000 hogan
après tu m as on va te parle et on ne
marque pas
les logan vous êtes décidément aussi
simples expliqué jean dire tout gentil
ça
[Musique]